[Music]
this episode of the Tim Farriss shows
brought to you by athletic greens I get
us all the time if I could only take one
supplement what would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all in one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens com forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
com forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn jobs hiring can be hard really
hard and it can also be super super
expensive and painful if you get it
wrong I certainly have had that
experience firsthand multiple times and
I am NOT eager to repeat it so I tried
to do as much vetting as possible on the
front end and today with more qualified
candidates than ever you need a solution
you need a platform that helps you to
find the right people for your business
LinkedIn jobs does exactly that more
than 600 million users visit LinkedIn to
learn make connections gross
professionals and more than ever
discover new job opportunities in fact
overall LinkedIn members add 15 new
skills to their profiles and apply to
thirty five job posts every two seconds
that's a crazy stat LinkedIn does the
legwork to match you to your most
qualified candidates so that you can
focus on the hiring process getting the
person into your company who will
transform your business they make sure
your job post gets in front of the
people with the right heart skills and
soft skills to meet your requirements
they've made it as easy as possible so
check it out to get $50 off of your
first job post go to linkedin.com slash
to him again that's linkedin.com slash
Tim to get $50 off of your first job
post terms and conditions apply but
check it out LinkedIn comm slash Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is always my
job each in every episode to speak with
a world-class performer and today
performer I suppose is very literal and
a lot of respects
and this wide-ranging conversation will
involve my guests Dita Von Teese Dita
Von Teese is the biggest name in
burlesque in the world since Gypsy Rose
Lee who was born in 1911 Dida is
credited with bringing the art form back
into the spotlight she is renowned for
her iconic martini glass act and
dazzling Haute Couture striptease
costumes Durand with hundreds of
thousands of Swarovski crystals this
burlesque super heroine as she's been
called by Vanity Fair is the performer
of choice at high-profile events for
designers such as Marc Jacobs Christian
Louboutin you'll have to excuse me for
my french louis vuitton show Parr and
Cartier among others she's the author of
The New York Times bestseller your
beauty mark subtitle the ultimate guide
to eccentric glamour and has a namesake
lingerie collection available
internationally at prominent retailers
she can be found on the socials on
twitter instagram facebook at Dita Von
Teese di ta vom t ee s e DITA welcome to
the show thank you and I have wanted to
meet for so long Amanda Palmer first
piqued my curiosity and there are so
many directions we could go but I
thought we would start with a word Haute
Couture which we started to talk about a
little bit because I didn't know what it
meant what is haute couture well I mean
it's like a term that's used very
loosely these days everyone wants to
call it something Haute Couture if it's
like extra special but it really means
high sewing like a high level of sewing
and so when you talk about a haute
couture designer it's you know there's
like a ministry of haute couture in
France where you kind of get the stamp
and you can call your clothing haute
couture so it's kind of loosely used you
know you'll find like - or doughnuts and
things like that you know but it's
really not accurate so I always say that
I do you know Haute strip so it's like a
high level of strip but
you know wearing Haute Couture costumes
which means they're you know made with
the with extravagance and excellence
that is not you know something you can
buy in a store
it's a speaking of things that you can't
buy easily in a store because you forged
your own path in a lot of respects I
would like to take a 90 degree turn I
suppose from where most people would
expect me to go and talk about vintage
cars so it's my understanding that
you've done very well in collecting
flipping refurbishing vintage cars yes
where does that come from well it first
started in the early 90s I was big into
the swing dance scene and pinup you know
a pinup model and I had a boyfriend that
drove a 1930s car and I sort of thought
I should have a 1930s car so I got my
first car in 1939 Chrysler New Yorker
when I was in my early 20s and I loved
that car and I used to drive it all
around Orange County where I lived and I
didn't I didn't I sold that car not that
long ago maybe like ten years ago and I
bought it for like $8,000 in the
nineties and sold it to someone in
Germany for like $30,000 so I thought
this is kind of I should do this more so
I started buying more cars I met a
really great guy that helps me with my
cars and so he goes to all the auctions
and finds things that a good price and
then we fix it up I Drive it for a while
because also for me with vintage cars I
like cars from the 30s 40s and 50s
but with vintage cars there's kind of
its like a relationship I've had cars
that I had a bad relationship with like
the brakes going out and you know
there's a I had this 65 Jaguar s-type
for a while that I loved it was so
beautiful I actually bought it on eBay
while I was drinking red wine and taking
ambien which was probably not the best
idea but so I picked up this car and I
was so beautiful
I picked it up when I was sober it was
still beautiful I was glad I bought it
but it was not a good fit for me because
the brakes kept going out on this car
and you could imagine that's really
terrifying yeah it sounds like a
downside
in particular that I remember was I was
pulling up to the Playboy Mansion and
you know this is like in the 90s when I
was like these amazing parties happening
and I remember going up the hill and
knowing the brakes were starting to fail
and just leaning out the window to all
the valets brakes don't work and they
all ran and you know I was going up the
hill quite slowly at that point but all
of these like valley guys running in
their red coats to stop the car so and
then I just got out went to the party
and you know had the car taking care of
the next day but it was one of those
things where I couldn't get I kept
taking it to mechanics and they were
like if the brakes are fine the brakes
are fine and then I'd get in it again
and then they'd go out on me so I feel
like you have to have the right fit with
a vintage car and so I I buy them I
drive them and I decide if it's the car
for me or not like - is it easy for me
to drive do I love how it feels to drive
it does it leave me on the side of the
road or not and so I've kind of just
right now I have three cars I have a
1953 Cadillac that I've had for a long
time a Fleetwood I've had that one for a
while and I love that one and I have a
1940 LaSalle which is a Cadillac it's a
convertible like a big black gangster
car really beautiful but I don't drive
it that much and then I just bought a
car it's called a Woodill wildfire and
it's a convertible it looks like the
Disney Cars car so I bought that one
actually to flip it because it's super
super rare and it's not really the kind
of car that I can cruise around LA and
because it'll be like a really you know
it'll go to Pebble Beach for sure next
year so I'll drive it for like a year
I'm having it all done up and then I'll
take pictures in it drive it enjoy it
and then you know flip that one it was
part of the ability to flip these cars
associated with the fact that you have
driven them or is that a selling point
or is that is that not part of the
selling process I think it's a little
bit of both I feel like vintage cars are
one of those things if you can keep them
for a long time they will always retain
their value it's just you have to not be
desperate to sell it and you can always
turn a profit but yeah like having you
know the picture is a video or you know
me getting photographed with it
that's you know but I don't just buy
them and take pictures of it and then
sell it you know I really use them I
really love them you know and you can
you collect or you have collected other
things or I should say vintage cars are
not the only vintage that you've
acquired in the past no I mean I pretty
much collect dead people's things
of all kinds my house is like a museum
I am a maximalist I love
I like recyclables too I like vintage
clothing because it's another thing that
retains its value I started wearing
vintage when I was just out of high
school I graduated from high school in
1990 and I bought vintage clothes
because I couldn't afford anything else
and I kind of wanted to get the designer
look you know I could emulate designers
like Vivienne Westwood or Jean Paul
Gautier by buying like vintage Bullitt
bras when you could buy them for nothing
and so I started like that cuz I
couldn't afford like you know the
designer jeans my friends in Orange
County had are the cool sneakers so I
kind of like went to flea markets and
went to vintage stores and then you know
lo and behold all these years later it's
super collectible and I have amassed an
amazing collection of vintage clothing
that has really has a lot of value it's
amazing how that works and it makes me
think of like my habits and hobbies with
comic books as a kid I mean I didn't
wire them to have them appreciate them
value but like you said lo and behold
it's a life lesson right like if you do
things with authenticity like that's
what I've always retained from theirs
it's a common thing of all of my life
lessons is like things that are
authentic if you do it in an authentic
way you know like what I never said I'm
gonna be the world's most famous
burlesque star I'm gonna be a stripper
in modern times I just did it
accidentally and it's the same thing
with collecting you know with the cars
and the vintage clothes it was sort of
like I just loved it and then I'm lucky
that it all worked out so we're gonna
we're gonna look at at at luck and we're
gonna look at decision
I think they go hand in hand very often
you have maybe not equal doses of each
but certainly doses of each let's let's
talk about burlesque but we're gonna
we're gonna do it kind of hopping
backwards and forwards the first
question that I wanted to ask is about
the name so Dita Von Teese where does
the name come from what's the backstory
on the name oh it's funny that one time
I remember a few years back someone was
talking a journalist's at how cliche my
name was how calculated in cliche it was
but it wasn't at all so I was working in
a strip club in the early 90s in Orange
County and I had picked the name DITA
cuz I had just seen a movie with an
actress called DITA parlo and then there
was also like the Madonna character in
the sex book and I kind of was you know
into this 20s look at the time I kind of
went through different eras that I loved
and emulated that so I picked the name
DITA and and then a few years later I
was asked to be in these Playboy
newsstand specials I don't know some
people remember this but they used to
have all these these special magazines
called the book of lingerie or whatever
so I was in those in like the mid 90s
and they told me I had to have a second
name so and I said no why Madonna cher
DITA what and they said no you have to
have a second name so I opened up the
phone book because we used to have
yellow pages back then or white pages
and I was like people with a Vaughn are
cool in their name so I looked under the
Vaughn's and I found this name Vaughn
Treece TR EE se and I called playboy and
I said I'm gonna be D davon Treece and
they're like okay and then I remember
the magazine came out and I went to the
liquor store and I grabbed my issue and
I opened it up and said Dita Von Teese
they forgot the R and now I wouldn't
think anything like oh this is cool it's
like striptease Dita Von Teese I thought
I need to call them and tell them you
know give them what for and so I called
him and said it was supposed to be Dita
Von trees and they said yeah yeah we'll
correct it next month so you know the
magazine came out again and it said Dita
Von Teese so it's just kind of I just
kind of left it and I didn't think
ever for one minute that I was going to
be famous with that name or I was going
to be trademarking it internationally I
would have probably done it differently
if I had known that it was going to turn
into what it has so I stood worked out
yeah but I was just you know I just like
working in a strip club do it posing for
these Playboy magazines and you know it
was something I thought I thought I
would just you know get married you know
have a baby and like that would be my
past of being this pinup star and in
stripper well it seems to me that
there's there's an argument that people
can make for planning big thinking big
and making those decisions with this
really long term outlook but I think
there's also an argument that could be
made if you look at a lot of the people
who have been on this podcast that if
they knew then what they knew later they
would have [ __ ] it all up by trying to
sort of craft themselves for the world
and they would have lost that
authenticity or that spontaneity that is
actually kind of the genie in the bottle
that helped them to do what they do yeah
what is burlesque and how did that enter
the scene because my understanding in
doing the research and also a you very
generously contributed your answers to
travel mentors is that ballet was one of
the I guess first focal points so how
did burlesque enter the picture and what
is brusque yeah okay so I wanted to be a
ballerina my whole childhood but I was
just not really that good at it I just
loved it and still to this day it's like
I like to take a ballet class but I'm
the ballerina in the back and I have to
follow every one and I just never had
that like I was just not naturally meant
to do that you know but I loved it so
burlesque was a type of show that was
sort of a spin-off of a vaudeville show
back in you know the 1930s and 40s so
vaudeville was kind of like where a lot
of you know amazing comedians and
singers kind of made their mark in
America
in the 1920s and 30s and you know pretty
much it was dead by the 40's but so
burlesque was kind of the naughtier
cousin of vaudeville it was a little bit
more about sex it was like a working
man's entertainment cheaper ticket you
could go and see what actually
originally it meant it was kind of just
a variety show but this the stars of the
burlesque show kind of became the
strippers and it was kind of by an
accident you know they say there was
like a dancing girl there's a few
different there's different folklore for
how it actually started how burlesque in
America really started that idea of
striptease to music with a band or on
stage there was one story about a girl
who was trying to do a quick change and
she started like pulling off her outfit
before she was concealed from the
audience and they went crazy and so you
know in those days it was like well you
know what can you do to get make a name
for yourself so obviously that turned
into like a striptease act but yeah it
was kind of like the strip club of that
time but you know there was a live
orchestra band and you had comedy and
dancing girls but you know you had great
stars that came out of burlesque like
Gypsy Rose Lee who a lot of people
compared me to or compared my career to
she was the subject of the musical and
film gypsy starring Natalie Wood which
came out in the 60s so burlesque was
kind of very niche entertainment I think
I don't think it's ever of course it
went away you know it got the burlesque
theaters got shut down in the 50s and
then burlesque dancers like Lily st. Cyr
were performing in like supper clubs and
and whatnot but burlesque was kind of
dead by the 50s in a lot of ways and so
it's dead in the 50s and yet somehow it
finds you yeah yeah or you find it and
you were born in working-class rural
Michigan is that right yes okay I was
born in Rochester but I grew up in a
place called West Branch Michigan which
is near Traverse City mm-hmm yeah and so
how did burlesque or striptease or any
of those
of entertainment or those iconic women
enter your life well I had this idea in
around 1991 that I wanted to be the new
Betty Page I wanted to create pinup
pictures with the emphasis on bondage
and fetishism as I kind of got
introduced to that world in a roundabout
way through my job working in a lingerie
store okay I worked in a lingerie store
I loved I've been obsessed with lingerie
since I was a little girl like I have
really distinct memories of being
curious about what these weird things
that women wore under their clothes were
like bras I sneaked into my mom's bra
drawer and I used to steal things and to
me it was like symbolic of womanhood and
femininity and I was like I want to be
part of this world you know so I was
always obsessed with lingerie anyway
I became obsessed with like things like
garter belts stockings when I was a
teenager I worked in a lingerie store I
asked someone for I had been looking for
like a Victorian corset and someone gave
me this gave me this address when I was
like 18 and I walked into the store or
they I supposedly could get something
like that and it was a fetish store and
it kind of opened my whole my mind this
whole other world that I had no idea
existed and I was shown this picture of
Bettie Page and I thought why isn't
anyone doing this now and I decided I
was going to be that and so in the
progress you know the process of me
making all these pinup pictures and even
bondage movies and all these things they
were from that you know in a 50s theme I
would be looking at these vintage
magazines and a lot of the models that
posed for these vintage magazines or
these fetish magazines that would say
they were a burlesque dancer - I was
like the burlesque dancer so a lot of
these women that posed for pin ups back
then and men's magazines in the 30s and
40s they were also dancers and I thought
like oh what a great way to use my
failed ballet career you know I could I
could you know perform
on stage and perform in these vintage
you know vintage outfits so I you know
my first stages for that were strip club
regular strip club and then as I became
more famous like with playboy and
everything I would headline the big
strip clubs all over the United States
and I get you know then suddenly I I was
the most famous fetish model in the
early 90s - so I was performing at this
like torture Garden in London and the
fetish ball here in LA and kind of doing
all these like fetish parties okay I
have so many questions so thank you for
that this is the your career and
trajectory so interesting to me on
multiple levels because and then I can
list off all the reasons but there's a
there's a the the perception that I have
is that the say strip club or stripping
striptease world is very would be very
difficult and very competitive because
you have a lot of beautiful women or
beautiful girls and the at least in some
places I would imagine the sort of
barrier to entry is is is decently low
and yet you were able to craft this this
unique career for yourself and really
differentiate yourself and I want to
harken back to something we were
chatting about before we started
recording which was Amanda Palmer in I
guess the the art of asking if I'm
getting the title right talked about you
because she contrasted what you did and
feel free to fact correct but with a lot
of what was happening at the time where
you'd have these sort of bleached blonde
women completely nude
you know enormous fake breasts doing
their thing getting kind of singles or
fives and you would have this elaborate
long striptease with much more clothing
and then there was one guy who would
give you a 50 it was like and that guy's
your customer yeah so I which which to
me is so beautiful because and I'm gonna
read
a quote here if I may this is from your
answer in tribal mentors if you could
have a gigantic billboard anywhere with
anything on it what would it say and why
and the quote that you gave was you can
be a juicy ripe peach and there will
still be someone who doesn't like
peaches and I'll just finish this real
quickly this is a quote that my friend's
great-grandmother told to her and she
told to me and I've always loved it and
you go on to say how in the public eye
as burlesque sorry I've been called
brilliant stupid ugly and beautiful in
equal measures but you found your niche
you found your true believers how did
you do that like when did you realize
that it could work was there a that's a
very long-winded lead-up to a question
but it's like you you broke through and
became so big in a world where I think
the belief would be that's extremely
extremely difficult so what like when
did you realize wow I think I'm onto
something or or you found that a secret
sauce yeah I feel like the first thing I
think about is that all along I was just
having fun and enjoying what I was doing
having the time of my life so it was
never high-stakes like how am I gonna
make it or break it I didn't really care
I always kept my normal job you know
while I was going to a club first I
worked in lingerie and then I worked in
makeup in beauty behind the makeup
counter at Robinson's me so I kind of
always kept my other my my job and so it
was never like if I don't make it what
am I gonna do I just felt like this is
fun so I think not having like that
pressure but there's certainly a couple
turning points in my career where I
mostly felt I had to live up to
accolades I was getting suddenly like
when I was on the cover of Playboy in
2002 for the Christmas edition it was
still a time when played what everybody
knew who was on the cover of Playboy and
people cared it was kind of before it
was all reality stars and it was when
you had like actresses wanting to be on
the cover so that was a pivotal moment
in my career and then
I was in Vanity Fair and they wrote this
article about what I did and I felt like
I better live up to some of this and
that kind of made me take myself more a
little bit more seriously and then I
came out with a book where I told my
story not in an autobiographical way but
a photo book which you just regan and
she kind of let me go wild with this
book and it was the first time that
HarperCollins and Regan books had done a
book like this where it was sort of
autobiographical but mostly a photo book
and on once it's called burlesque and
the art of the tease and fetish in the
art of the tease and it was a book where
he could flip it over and read the other
side the the light side and the dark
side and I found I did this big book
signing in London at Harrods and the
night before I went on the Jonathan Ross
show and when I showed up they had
blocked off the streets and there were
thousands of women there there it was
like a sea of like girls with red
lipstick on and I suddenly went oh I
didn't know that I'm standing for
something now and I realized that by
just telling my story about feeling like
I wasn't you know wasn't very beautiful
wasn't very talented all these things it
kind of you know resonated with other
people that said I felt that way too and
I kind of just felt like I had a mission
and something to stand up for and
realized that all has to just come from
speaking my truth and being authentic
and not like calculating because you
know talking about what we're saying
earlier there's so many people that want
to be the new me and they're gonna be
more Dita Von Teese than Dita Von Teese
was and they're gonna make their career
and they're gonna be more famous than me
and do better than me you know I hear it
all the time but it's like you can't
really you know you can try to make it
up and you can decide you're going to do
all those things but I think ultimately
you know I'm not like super spiritual
like the universe is watching but I just
feel like my whole career path is just a
matter of doing something that I loved
that I believed in but without the
desire or want to be famous
I wanted to be acknowledged certainly
but I didn't expect it mm-hmm when did
you when did you know you could make it
a full-time gig so I'm thinking about
the road leading up to the cover of
Playboy I would imagine a few things
happened leading up to that when did you
end up quitting those backup jobs I
think I ended up quitting those jobs
around 2008 mm maybe like right before
Playboy and that's when I was really
touring and and shooting pictures and I
also met my ex-husband Marilyn Manson a
lot of people know me because of him
he's always been a cheerleader for what
I do and still is in a lot of ways so I
think that that was a moment to where I
felt like I could focus completely on
showbiz instead of my paycheck because I
was also like let's be real I was you
know basically his cook I'm a good cook
I was sort of like the housewife and
took care of him while he was making
records he made a record called the
Golden Age of grotesque which was sort
of a tribute to my world and you know
around that time I was sort of you know
moved in with him we got engaged and I
was you know packing his suitcases
unpacking his suitcase vo acting like
personal assistant half the time but
also had the freedom to you know start
building you know put big props up in in
our backyard and rehearse on them and
make bigger better show so that was kind
of a moment where I could focus more on
that mm-hmm
you have said that the advice will
actually no I'm gonna come back to the
advice not the advice to your younger
self but that you're your 16 year old
self might be surprised that you've
managed to find your voice and that you
experienced a lot of fear as a kid and
you do I mean just in our interactions
leading up to recording I mean you you
seem very in some ways very introverted
or on the shy side which is not a bad
thing how did you find your voice
what changed yeah I mean I grew up
really shy like I remember being in
grade school and being sent but I mean I
was sort of always confused by this but
they sent me to like a speech class or
something like this because I was so
soft-spoken but mostly I was just
terrified for them to ask me anything or
calling me and I felt that way through
high school and everything I could have
never you know I used to duck out of
speech class like or you know in high
school when you'd have to give speeches
oh I would never you know I've never
went to a theater I didn't want to be an
actress nothing like that but I liked
you know I liked ballet I liked
performing but that was different and I
feel like I found my confidence actually
with first it's one of the things I talk
about with my book is learning how to
find confidence in how I present myself
and and you know listen it's it's like
it's like drag the way we dress
ourselves the way we wear a hair the
makeup we wear I feel more confidence
than when I'm you know with the
character I created which is not you
know I don't it's a character but it's
not it's like an aesthetic character but
I'm not I still find the importance in
being still the Heather sweet from
Michigan and then vulnerability coming
across not just with the appearance I've
created but onstage with how I perform
Heather sweet for people who don't know
your birth name yeah I'm Heather sweet
it sounds like a stripper name I know my
yeah about confidence and the when you
put on the and I'm just paraphrasing
here but when you put on the persona
that allows you to assume a level of
confidence that you don't normally know
like wearing wearing my makeup a certain
way and wearing my clothes that changed
my posture and make me want to walk
proud or people wanting to wondering who
I am who's that girl
you know it slowly but surely helped me
gain confidence and
and of course there are I feel like it's
it's definitely about maturity - right
like we're you know when you're in high
school you're a certain maturity level
it's just when you think about the
science of it - and I just kind of
thought eventually I learned that if I
make mistakes in front of people it
peeps there are people that are all
saying I'm like that too and it's
endearing so when I was a spokesperson
for the MAC AIDS Fund for the Mac Viva
Glam thing and I had to give speeches
all over the world and I was so scared
but then I realized that once I got up
there and I'd have a have a triumph it
made me have more confidence and so I
love to challenge myself and doing
things that terrify me you know I have
never been a singer I cannot sing but I
got asked to make an album by one of the
greatest French musicians and I thought
okay you know I said to him you know I
can't sing right and he said this album
wouldn't work with the singer and I
wrote it for you and I thought okay and
just the whole process of going into a
studio and being you know around all
these like sound technicians and this
artist that I admire so much and like
learning and going to that place of
feeling like Heather sweet from Michigan
again I enjoy it and I come out of it
you know and it's one of the things I
think my fans and people that know me
like about me is that I'm not trying to
like look at me I'm so glamorous and I
have confidence in everything I do like
I don't talk like that I don't act like
that you know I know how to bring it
onstage but I also know that the little
things that are the real me are what
make it an interesting thing to watch
see mentioned feeling terrified
I want to wind back the clock a bit and
because I I deliberately didn't want to
kind of fill in the gaps on on some
chapters in your life because I wanted
to hear it from you directly also
because I can't believe everything you
read on the Internet
were you is it true that you're that you
were thrown out of your house in high
school yeah well my parents were getting
a divorce I always feel so bad talking
about this for my dad because he'll you
know it's one of those things I
really gotten around to like sitting
down and talking to him about but I will
so my parents were getting a divorce my
mother was having an affair with my
dad's best friend my dad was having an
affair with his mistress back in
Michigan we're all living in Orange
County at that time they're both having
this like you know their affairs at
these different people I'm 16 years old
I'm working in the lingerie store I have
the same boyfriend since I was like 14
years old you know I'm living my life
I'm working I'm going to school and
working I'm hanging out with my
boyfriend I'm not you know pretty I'm
not getting amazing grades but I'm not
getting bad grades I don't do anything
bad
and I'm working in the lingerie store
and I'd wash my little like black lace
lingerie things and hang them up in my
bathroom and my dad just had like a fit
about it and was calling me you know a
[ __ ] and like whoring around with your
boyfriend and I was sort of like what
you know like I have a credit card I'm
working a lingerie store selling
lingerie to like you know grown women
and it's a legitimate it's not a sex
store it's you know I'm selling like
night gowns to ladies and their 50s half
the time so my dad like kind of threw me
out of the house and he was drinking a
lot at that time so I went to go live
with my mom which was better for me
because I've always been closer to my
mom and we've always understood each
other a lot better than you know dads
and daughters don't always understand
each other that well so that's the story
of me getting thrown out of the house
was that was that hard for you I'm just
I mean I've never been thrown out of a
house made of weave I've I've certainly
had my own childhood stuff but was it
was it more of a relief than anything
yeah it was kind of like I feel like I
could recognize whatever my parents were
going through and that you know a
divorce is never easy on anyone and I
was sort of like it's you know I was
always very like relaxed about things
like that and even looking back it
wasn't traumatic I sort of just went and
lived with my mom and
you know I had more freedom that way it
wasn't you know it wasn't long after
that that I uh you know moved out you
know it was a couple years later that I
was kind of on my own and yeah I don't I
don't know it was more it made me think
about it a few years ago I didn't think
about that too much but it made me think
about how people have their own
associations with certain things and and
my association with lingerie and black
lace and garter belts and stockings was
kind of an innocent one like I said it
goes back to that rite of passage of
being a woman not sex you know certainly
I know how to use the tools of seduction
and things like lingerie and I have used
that in my personal life but you know I
don't it's never been that for me and I
thought oh that's my dad putting his
issues on me it's not about me and I
still think that and that's the
conversation I need to have with my dad
is like I do understand that something
that made him associate black garter
belts and late black lace with something
bad with a wicked city woman and a
prostitute he was really disturbed by
his you know 16 17 year old daughter
wearing that stuff but none of that was
my problem that's his problem how did
you develop the capacity to handle all
of that as calmly as you did it was is
your mom that way are you did you
somehow develop that over time I mean
that seems atypical for a 16 or 17 year
old getting thrown out of the house to
be to be able to watch The Watcher in a
way and have that level of kind of calm
awareness
I'm not necessarily I'm not really sure
if I felt that way at the time but I
think I've always been someone who you
know kind of disappears into the work
whatever it is and I kind of I don't I'm
not someone who reacts unless I'm really
like provoked and pushed and then
suddenly I can explode but I certainly
wasn't
that way when I was a teenager I think
things would be different now if someone
like my dad talked to me and even when
he does talk to me you know if I if he
says something I don't agree with her
that I'm offended by like I wouldn't be
that person that's like I'm just gonna
go I'm a little more confrontational
with with my father now you know you
mentioned the ballet and wanting to be a
ballet dancer and I want to come back to
that because going back to one of the
questions and tribe mentors I asked you
know how is a failure or apparent
failure set you up for later success do
you have a quote favorite failure and
quote of yours and there's a lot to the
answer so I'm not going to read all of
it which is a great answer but you
mentioned at one point you know
truthfully I never really loved dancing
per se I loved with ballet stood forth
and then you went into what that meant
and the part I want to highlight here is
I believe that sometimes our
shortcomings can lead to greatness
because those of us who have intense
desire but lack natural god-given talent
sometimes find roundabout ways of
realizing dreams so this I think is
really really really important because
there are certain places certain fields
of endeavor certain careers that require
mutant like attributes that you're
either born with or you are born without
I agree and if you want to sprint along
say alongside who say in bolt good luck
thank you better have some very unusual
genetics if you want to be a superstar
ballet dancer at the top of the world
similarly you need there's a certain
phenotype a certain build and there are
attributes that are prerequisites in a
lot of respects you managed to take your
abilities in different areas and combine
them into something unique what are
other either failures that help you
the way or key decisions that you think
have helped you to craft this very
unusual path for yourself yeah for some
reason I've always loved people that are
have like shortcomings or when you read
you always read about people's opinions
like oh she's not that good of a singer
why is she the most famous singer in the
world they're better you know I always
loved those people yeah and so I'm kind
of you know because I can relate to them
you know and I those are always the kind
of singers I like like I can't stand
listening to vocal gymnastics like when
people are like the great singers of
today I like people to have flawed
voices or interesting voices that have
like commute that communicate and I
always felt the same way about dance and
myself like I'm just trying to
communicate I'm trying to be on stage
instead of look like I'm trying to dance
you know I get insulted a lot with she's
not that good of a dancer even you know
like oh actually I probably could be but
I don't want ever look like I'm trying
too hard because to me like sensuality
and eroticism is an epic fail if you
look like you're trying to do it it's
better to do less yeah you know I mean
like I I even think when I watch someone
like Beyonce her best moments are when
she stops you know she does all this
crazy stuff and then she stops and
breathes and you're like yes do the more
of that you know it's so great so I I'm
that's that's just I think that my
failures and not really finding what
that thing that I might be amazing at is
because I also I'm always fascinated by
what you were saying like how does
someone you think of all these people
that are walking around and what if they
could have been the greatest whatever
but they were never given the
opportunity or they weren't interested
in it like what if they could have been
the best like basketball player or they
could have been the best actor but like
they never had the opportunity or the
interest in trying it and there's
probably people out there with hidden
talents it could have been the best in
the world and they would never even know
it
and I think that you know why I like
this this answer you gave and this topic
is that whether it's people listening
whether it's you and what you've done
you're not limited to 27 preset tracks
called careers like you can be the best
in the world but you have to figure out
how to be the best Dita Von Teese in the
world if you're Dita Von Teese and you
mentioned you know people trying to out
DITA detail like that's never gonna
[ __ ] work right because they're try
but like they're they should race their
own race right yes I they're they're not
going to have the endurance or the
enthusiasm of the passion or the lack of
attachment that you had in the beginning
so they've kind of in a way already lost
ain't like they're they're they're
trying to dominate in a category of one
which is already owned by DITA and I
think quite a bit I've had two folks on
this podcast Marc Andreessen is a very
famous entrepreneur and an investor and
then scott adams the creator of Dilbert
and both of them have very similar
thoughts on building incredible careers
or finding your own path which is in a
sense and this came from scott first in
his writing is you can try to be the top
1% of 1% of 1% in one thing like
basketball mm-hmm
but you are gonna have a hell of a time
doing that and you you are gonna be
relying heavily on attributes that you
are either born with or without and that
is a sort of a finite game in a sense
and then you on the other hand you could
combine really unusual
I shouldn't say unusual things you could
take usual things that are usually not
combined like a law degree and a
computer science degree and fill in the
blank a love of Japanese anime I'm just
making that up now all of a sudden
you're the one horse in the race
yeah right what other you've mentioned a
few of the women who have inspired you
are there any other whether it's women
inside or outside of burlesque or really
anywhere who inspire you
along those lines kind of people who
have have carved their own path he
mentioned Madonna earlier this is
something I also wanted to mention like
she's had people throughout her career
say oh she's not she doesn't know how to
sing she has no idea how to dance or
whatever it is she makes a movie she
can't act yes she directs the movie she
can't direct but she's [ __ ] Madonna
like why is she Madonna lie has a really
worthwhile question to ask for decades
she was Madonna right I mean she still
has Madonna but like she's she's been
able to reinvent herself successfully so
many times and it's because she is the
best at combining all those disparate
but not only that people sometimes
forget and this is the thing that
bothers me she was the first person to
sort of like I'm gonna make a music
video on stage and those shows with all
the dancers and you know all of it
around her she was the person that was
like I'm going to make this stage show
that is like a spectacle and so every
you know what bothers me is that you
people definitely have every show that's
the benchmark now everyone has to try to
have all these dancers they have to have
designers making their outfits they have
to do all this stuff but sometimes they
these people will forget where they
wouldn't even she's the one that paved
the way for that and inspired everyone
to do that and you know I bothered me
when somebody doesn't get credit for
that you know yeah for sure I mean cuz I
watch people all the time that are like
they'll imitate one of my shows but then
they act like they never saw me but when
they've never heard of me before you
know because there's always that
everybody wants to be recognized they
want to be feel like they did something
that was the first thing you know and
they changed the world and but it's
honestly like why don't you do that
first you know and then you can instead
of just trying to sweep it under the rug
that you saw you know you saw somebody
else do it and you decided you were
going to try to make it better but you
didn't no I agree
I totally agree are there what other
notable influences have you had any
gender any discipline it's anyone come
to mind there's there's one that I can
definitely bring up just because I think
she's amazing but no no I want to hear
Madonna okay
no no Madonna well I was the one
there no no I brought her up as as just
someone top of mine that I didn't want
to forget well let's just jump to it Mae
West oh yeah Mae West Mae West who is
Mae West boludo no she's okay she was an
actress that is I think there's still no
one that's ever done what she has do you
know much about Mae West very little
other than what you wrote about her just
because of her her incredibly well
titled book on sex health and ESP yeah
very rare book yes but also her quotes
I've just found her quotes to be so
brilliant in all right I've had a few
too many cappuccinos prior to this
interview just why I'm all over the
place but I just to get it out there so
when when I get attacked by someone on
the internet usually I don't reply you
before that I don't even go looking for
it but if I just happen to be having a
tough day and and I and I come across
someone and feel compelled to feed the
trolls I will very often respond it's
usually because I've offended somebody
in some ridiculous way and I'll almost
always just reply with I'm wait Mae West
quote which is those were shocked easily
she'd be shocked more often yeah and I
just let her to my speaking for me but
who is okay so may West is as
fascinating she was the biggest sex
symbol in the 1930s and the things that
make her fascinating the short version
are number one she made her first film
at age 40 and she was the biggest sex
symbol of her time
so that's imagine that now also she
wrote every line she ever said in every
film so when you look at Mae West quotes
and you will get like the best quotes
ever written the best one-liners ever
written you know she is that like and
that's what she said you know she's like
the originator of that kind of quote so
and then she went to the studio bosses
when she made her first films and became
a sensation she said how much does the
studio boss get I want more than that
and she got more than that
and she was the only person she was the
only actor actress that made more than
the studio bosses just because she asked
for it and she demanded it and she was
you know a sensation back then so she's
kind of like a sexual gangster too you
know she was the one that flipped the
script everything was you know women
were had a certain role in Hollywood and
she was kind of like the male version
and she even when you watch her film
she's objectifying men left and right
it's just it's astonishing to watch and
I can't think of anyone in history
that's done what she's done since I mean
to actually write every line in every
film is kind of and she made so many
films and of course you know she's there
there are some of her things about her
that are problematic because it was a
different time but you know what kind of
stuff is problematic well you know I
mean they she she appear even there's a
great documentary coming out about her I
hope people will watch but you know she
grew up a lot of people say she
appropriated black culture with the with
her likes her swagger and the way she
sang and talked and everything and that
was kind of an imprint of childhood
because she was actually like a child
actor in a minstrel show so that was
kind of like she just picked it up you
know and turned it into something
totally different so that's you know
that's one thing but you know then we
could also argue like she completely
swirled it into something new and became
Mae West and you know Mae West is like
this character that you know there's
never been another another one like her
and you know she's tried Queens do Mae
West everyone does Mae West you know
it's like this character that we've
never seen again and and when you squint
your eyes or like that's Mae West
so yeah she's someone I definitely
admire she went to prison for like
writing a play about sex I mean she was
talking she was sex positive in a time
before it was popular I mean she wrote a
play called sex I think she went to
prison for like a week but you know she
loved it because she got to hang around
all these other women and write more
material and she felt like she came out
better than ever because of workshopped
yeah yeah so she is a fascinating person
I'm glad they're finally there's some
great books about her that when my
favorite one is she always knew how
but she also wrote that's the name of it
yeah she always knew how that's a
biography about her that I really like
there's several and of course she wrote
an autobiography
and if you can ever get your hands on
love sex and ESP is a love a second okay
so sex helps health and use ESP sorry
that book is great I used to read aloud
from that book in in Paris I'd get my
friend I lived in Paris for a short time
and I got my friends together and we'd
all drink champagne and read aloud from
that book because it's so crazy you have
a favorite and he you have a favorite
film of hers no really it's like one
that you would suggest people start with
it's hard to say I would suggest anybody
who interested just go and start
watching Mae West clips like watching
some best doves like reels of her quick
one-liners of the things she would say
that that's what I would say cuz it's
one of those things where the clips are
almost better than the films and they're
on their own
mm-hmm you were just talking about the
West writing her own lines
and I read something that may or may not
be true you can tell made you use
stylists or do not use stylists I don't
in my personal life I am forced to often
in my professional life like for
photoshoots for a magazine and whatnot
but I am self style you know I when I go
on the red carpet I can't I just pull
from my own wardrobe or I have direct
relationships with the designers I've
which has kind of always been you know a
good good thing for me is having that
direct contact with the people that I
want to be dressed by that whole machine
of like hair makeup stylist like I can't
I can't be bothered with all of it I
don't need it I feel like I know if it
looks right it is right and and also
that's kind of what I built my whole
career on is being self-made and you
know in my books empowering other women
to be able to do whatever I can do I
don't know if this is apocryphal or if
it's a real story but I had read of some
stylist picking up some very
I suppose classic vintage shoes and
saying oh these would go great with
jeans and you're like okay I think we're
done yeah yeah it was actually Marilyn
Manson's stylist and we live together
and she was like oh yeah let's go look
in your wardrobe and she's a good friend
of mine now and it's all fine you know
it's just that I always you know I I
figured out early on that I didn't need
advice you know I don't I don't need
advice I want to wear I know what to
wear prep for your shows let's talk
about prep so I had read that you arrive
sometimes four or five hours in advance
of your performances yes and that you
could prep you could get ready very
quickly but you choose not to yeah it's
a nightmare why why do you arrive as
someone who arrives to the airport like
17 hours early for domestic flights I
feel like it might be birds of a feather
in that respect but why do you arrive so
early
well there are a lot of you know yes I
can get ready within a certain timeframe
but when you start throwing in all of
these things like answering text
messages and people asking you questions
you know when I'm doing my tours I
arrive like five six hours before
because there's things like I want to go
look at the theater I need to go look at
the stage sometimes you know I need to
set where the props are going to go
because the stage is a different size
than usual but mostly it's like why rush
it's part of the fun of it is getting
ready I love listening to music I love
listening to Tim Ferriss podcasts in my
dressing room
thank you that particularly the one it's
about psychedelic drugs and and I am I
just like taking my time you know
there's when you I'm in such a better
headspace when I spend much too much
time preparing I have um I have a lot of
bad experiences with being rushed I mean
most recently I was performing at this
party for Anastasia of Beverly Hills it
was like all the Kardashians in presence
and I was sort of like in the dress
singing room and there were some
Kardashian's in there and I was like to
me being kind of bombarded and rapped
and and you know I get really stressed
out when I'm being rushed you know to
get ready and I kind of got like can you
go onstage in 15 minutes and I was like
ah you know it's not how I want to do it
that's not the way that I want to feel I
don't want to feel stressed out or
rushed or like you know cuz I feel like
that's when I start getting in my head
and I'll be like I'm not good and you
know all the bad things in my head like
I'm not good enough yeah I can't I don't
know what I'm doing they're gonna find
out I'm pretending to do this they're
gonna find out I have no idea what I'm
doing
yeah I the the on ramp to a lot of these
experiences for me is as important as
the so called performance segments right
it's like me I have always arrived so
early I mean this is this where we're
sitting right now as a case in point
right I mean I'm I'm here for a 45 or 60
minute panel tomorrow I could have
arrived a few hours beforehand but I
want to know the venue I want to feel
comfortable in the time zone I want to
know what I'm gonna be having for
breakfast so that I don't have any snafu
I want to know if the minibar has like
snacks I want to know all of those
details even though I will probably not
need any of those contingency plans it
just gives me a level of calm and
feeling is that I've checked the boxes
so that the only thing occupying my mind
is what I am going to do once I get on
stage yeah otherwise and I have friends
I envy them who like they they almost
make it a game to see how close they can
cut it at the airport when your flights
I that is so much it's just so Anathem
I think it makes a whole lot of sense to
arrive really really really early so for
those people who are making stress sport
with things like transportation I
encourage you like consider the
alternative which is not
living just like an hour beforehand but
like with an excess of time yeah but
stress Sport is a good word yeah who
needs it
who needs it yeah there's enough
unavoidable unpredictable stress I feel
no compulsion to add optional stress of
my own volition what what would you say
are any behave new behaviors or beliefs
that have really positively impacted
your life in the last year two or three
is there anything anything that you've
really changed for yourself added or
removed that has had a significant
impact on your well-being would you say
well I know a lot of people say this but
learning to meditate which I'm not a
good great amazing model meditator I use
it when I need it and that's kind of
helped me you know in a lot of ways
meditation Transcendental Meditation you
know I feel like when I you know it was
always intimidating to me I think I
dropped into like a Buddhist meditation
center once and I was like oh my god
sitting here for an hour but you know
the thoughts and it scared me away and
then someone introduced me to
Transcendental Meditation I learned with
this amazing lady and she you know she
had all these great stories about
teaching Elizabeth Taylor to meditate
and Michael Jackson and all these people
and she had great stories so it made it
fun for me too to see her for all the
training every day I was like oh it's
story you're gonna tell me now so and
then she also just took the pressure off
and and when I would say like I don't
think I can sit there for 20 minutes
twice a day she said why don't you try
10 and I was like okay so having that
pressure off and even though just
realizing five minutes is good that that
seemed to help a lot and I'm trying to
be better at it and it's something that
gives me a goal to to achieve to like to
try it to make sure I block out the time
what differences have you seen
starting to experiment with the
meditation well I think it's mostly like
regaining focus and having I also
besides like Transcendental Meditation
clearing my mind I also love to schedule
like a massage or something that puts me
in a relaxed state but still a thinking
state because I don't like it's not like
I'm trying to just tune out then I start
like actually thinking about what I'm
gonna do that's where I come up with my
good ideas where I'm like what what's my
new tour gonna be called and I love to
set aside that time of not doing and
racing around and not you know trying to
accomplish things and just like I'm
gonna lay here for an hour and think
about this thing that I need to figure
out I can do that the dentist too
sometimes actually a dentist yeah I kind
of don't mind really going to the
dentist and it kind of makes me close my
eyes and like think about things yeah
yeah so so it's it's more like taking a
time out because I have always these
to-do lists and I feel realize I'm you
know trying to chip away at it and doing
too many things and I think I just need
to it makes my life better when I stop
and I focus you know clear my mind close
my eyes meditate yeah yeah the
transitional meditation is is a
fantastic option for people who have
developed very well earned I think or
well deserved on the part of meditation
allergy to meditation because the way
that meditation is often sold is very
all-or-nothing and extremely
intimidating right you're gonna sit on
this hard floor for an hour with
perfectly straight back and do X whereas
TM especially with a good teacher
can keep lowering the bar until it's
easy to step over it's not something you
have to do you know Olympic high jump
over here they they make it less and
less intimidating until you can get
started
then once you're sitting there for ten
minutes you're like okay thank you often
object okay I can go 15 okay I can go 20
but it's really just getting your ass to
sit down do it and the first leg for me
the first five minutes is brutal
and then suddenly I go and do it like
the zone I'm like oh yeah this is what I
came here for yeah and it really does as
a mantra based concentration practice
train you at least it hasn't been my
experience
you said helping with focus to return to
something over and over again and like
you'll end up drifting off and thinking
about your to-do list or porn or
whatever and then you're like oh wait
I'm supposed to be meditating and then
you go back to your mantra and when you
sit down in front of computer you sit
down with a notebook that's also what
you're going to be doing right so it's
like the reeling back is the repetition
of lifting the weight in the gym and
it's it's a very it's a very beneficial
gateway drug into meditation yeah I
think I also love taking a time out
during the day actually by myself
and sipping a little magic mushroom tea
and oh okay this is what you know kind
of gets to the essence of things like a
simplistic appreciation for the beauty
of the world I just you know you know I
can look in the garden and I'm like oh
yeah okay yeah I do this once in a while
that'll definitely do it yeah what no
there's there's advice I referred to
earlier to younger self and the the the
advice that you gave in tribal mentors
was actually no it wasn't interrupt
mentors I take it back
this was in an interview was an effect
to be a little bit more vigilant right
to look over your books to pay attention
so that you wouldn't be taken advantage
of
because the world we live in
it's a full-contact you know for better
for worse if you're going to be on the
playing field like there are gonna be
people who want to separate you from
your money and many other things is
there is there any other advice that you
would give to your actually yes you
two younger self and and you can pick
the age so that's the thing so it could
be yourself of five years ago could be
yourself at age six could be any age how
old would you be and what advice would
you give that version of yourself I
think in my mid-twenties I would have
told myself to try to maybe buy a house
like even if it was something small I
would have done that and I would have
also warned myself about signing model
releases because although there are lots
of people that really like our kind and
like did you know I didn't know I was
going to be famous but there are some
people that took advantage of that yeah
you know like suddenly I was in ad
campaigns with without you know with a
watch photoshopped on my hand because
someone took a portrait of me when I was
like 25 and then they used it ten years
later so there were things like that
which you know I just I didn't really
you know I didn't have any anticipation
that that kind of thing would happen to
me I was just like oh yeah that's fine
I'm this sign whatever was in front of
me but you know I guess people could
have taken advantage of me no matter
what
yeah if they wanted what what advice do
you think yourself ten years from now
would give you our current self that
gosh it's hard to take advice from your
yeah well if you were giving if your
older self we're giving your current
self advice
meaning you right now we're getting
advice from your older self what do you
think your older self would say oh god
I'm worried that my I'm worried that my
older self might say that I should have
had a child I'm concerned about that you
know I'm not concerned about right now
yeah but sometimes I go oh god I really
hope that doesn't happen
mmm and then I think well there's always
remedies for that too though you know
there's you could adopt any time you
know because it's really one of those
things where I know sometimes I wish
when it comes to children and people
that have children
I don't really envy any of my friends
with chill
except for adult children like oh that's
so cool you have this great adult child
that's doing amazing things that is
probably fun to hang out with but it
doesn't always work out like that you
know it doesn't always work out like
that so um you know I just it's hard
when you're in the line of work that I'm
in you know I I can't think of a time
where I ever could have stopped and said
oh I think I'll just have a baby and
then I think about who I would have had
a baby with back then like probably not
the best idea yeah so you know it's a
real it's a what can you do you know I
feel like I chose my path I don't
necessarily feel like it's the right
time for everyone to bring children the
world and anyway but hmm no I think I
think that you know I I have friends who
have kids who are very happy I have
friends who have kids who are totally
miserable and I have friends without
kids who are both very happy and some
who are very miserable right yeah I
think it's kind of another variable
are you having children interested you
know I appreciate you asking uh I don't
have kids that I'm aware of currently I
did not plan there's a long period of
time where I did not plan on having kids
in part because I was afraid of [ __ ]
them up in some way mm-hmm and that I
felt like the risk that the decision to
bring a child into the world was
inherently a selfish one in a way right
like you're not doing it for your kids
in a sense you're doing it because you
want kids
yes number one and that if there were
potential risk of or almost a guarantee
that you're going to damage your kids in
some way and certainly I don't know
anyone who's made it out of childhood
unscathed
okay there's like [ __ ] goes sideways
that I didn't feel like that was a risk
I wanted to take if that makes any sense
I've started to feel differently about
it is it because you're newly in love
though cuz that's the thing you already
a past that like
new love thing and that ya know cuz
that's like a science of like I should
have a baby I mean yeah you get kind of
slap back yeah yeah I am with a
wonderful woman my girlfriend that's
that's a piece of it for sure I think
that also I've done just a lot of work
in the last handful of years and have
come to a place where I feel confident
that I could be a at the very least like
a B+ parent I don't know if I'd be an A+
parent but I think I could be at least a
b-plus parent and also I think that
there may just be a like biological
imperative and sort of existential itch
that is hard to scratch without having
kids and so that you know a friend of
mine said to me recently he said you can
find meaning by finding God or having
kids having kids is easier so there may
be an element of sort of inevitability
in in a sense but I think I've also just
come to accept that part of the human
experience is making mistakes and if the
every parent makes mistakes and is going
to condition their kids in ways they
don't want to consciously or
subconsciously and that if you're going
to sign up for having kids you should
just accept on the front end that you're
gonna do damage and hopefully you help
them undo it later and you'll have level
of self-awareness to do that so I would
leave mud like the have kids ohmmeter is
is kind of leaning more towards having
kids yeah it was a lot for me yeah but
ultimately it I just think mostly about
like adoption or you know yeah I love
animals
me too no yeah me too it's not I know
it's not the same thing
it is like you know I it's not the same
thing but the thing is off a lot I know
it but it's not the same thing but there
are a lot of parallels this is gonna
upset a lot of ya because they're like
little children are not animals or
whatever I'm like actually they
technically are exactly animals being
mammals and all and there's a there's a
great book called don't shoot the dog
which is terribly titled but a fantastic
book on in effect training of mammals
and it talks a lot about I'm gonna get
so much [ __ ] for this that's okay
training of dolphins so you can only
really effectively use positive
reinforcement let's say dolphins or
aquatic mammals because you're not gonna
hit them with a rolled-up newspaper like
it doesn't work if they're just got swim
away from you so you have to get very
good at using cues like a whistle or
something like that to indicate the
behavior as a marker and then rewarding
and it turns out you can use that for
training just about anything and one of
the quotes I believe it was in that book
that I loved so much was you know if you
can't train a chicken you shouldn't be
allowed to have a child and I tend to
believe that it's like if if you're not
if you can't be aware of your impact on
another animal and how it shapes that
animal's behavior I don't think in on
some level and of course legally this
has no hole to no water whatsoever but
ethically perhaps you shouldn't be
allowed to have kids like you should be
able to pass that test and I have a dog
now adopted her a few years ago about
three three and a half years ago and
I've satisfied for myself that I can at
least keep a medium-sized mammal alive
and healthy for that period of time and
so we'll see anyway I'm talking too much
but I think that's in part because it's
it's been on the brain and like you it
it flips and flops yeah when I go to the
airport and I see like kids having a
complete meltdown and there
it's like pulling their hair out and
just having a hellish time of going
through the process I'm like I'm not
sure I just think like also I've been
asked about it my whole adult life and I
think what you know in interviews and I
just always thought like what if you
were asking someone that could not have
children you know and why do we have to
put so much emphasis on if you don't
have children you're not your life isn't
full and you haven't done the most
important job there is in the world
because there are lots of people that
can't have children for different reason
does that make them less of a person so
that's one of the problems I have with
people always putting so much emphasis
on the importance of being a mother it's
like it's kind of when you think about
it you know it's kind of not very cool
to ask people about that or to make that
statement that that it's the most
important job in the world
yeah I don't think it should be the
number one priority for everyone I don't
think any one thing should be that I can
think of should be the number one
priority for and everyone just doesn't
make any sense and like you said there
are many cases in which for physical
medical or other reasons it's it makes a
whole lot of sense not to not to take
the sort of biological birthing route or
necessarily adopt like I know people who
I mean friends of my parents and others
who went their entire lives without kids
and had very very deep rich fulfilling
lives and did a lot of good the world so
yeah
in my case TBD still TBD one thing I
love in life is knowing women much older
than me and asking for their advice like
the thing that you asked me about
earlier about watching my finances that
advice came from 1950s movie star pinup
model who's still around now Mamie Van
Doren
she's like a blonde bombshell she was
kind of like a Marilyn Monroe but anyway
she was she was a big star back then but
anyway I know her and I love to sit down
with her and have her give me advice and
that was one of her things like watch
your money I know it's not
fun and it's not fun to look at numbers
and challenge people but watch it all
and she also had said to me she has one
son and she was like I love my son but
it wasn't the most important thing I did
in life it wasn't it's not something you
have to do if you don't feel inclined
and she said and if I'm looking at the
world today the way I'm looking at the
world today as compared to how it was in
the 50s and 60s and 70s she's like I
wouldn't do it now so I thought that was
interesting I like talking I have
another friend named Ilona Roy Smith
skin who's a hundred years old and I
loved getting on the phone with her and
hearing she still has amazing advice
change that any advice come to mind
she's good from her well she she just
has little pearls of wisdom she has an
Instagram that I love to follow and she
just puts it out there all the time
about mostly she's a hundred yeah she
does and she's an amazing lady she has
she's I learned about her from a book
called advance style by my friend Ari
Seth Cohen I don't know if you've heard
about this book but it's about he was
obsessed with finding older ladies that
dress in eccentric ways and wear
eccentric makeup and that are you know
fashion icons in their own right
eccentric people and I learned about her
because she had she's like four feet
tall she has this flaming orange hair
and she makes her own eyelashes like
long red eyelashes blue eye shadow and
she's an artist and she's you know she
has a show I think too like she's a
singer just like in Provincetown anyway
she's like she's a surrogate
her name's Ilona Royce Smith skin' oh
boy how do you spell Ilona I I L oh yeah
all right and we'll put it in the show
notes as well okay for her Instagram and
so on yeah all right she's into me but
his book in general is amazing because
it spotlights all these like you know
elderly people and you know there's a
lot of talk about you shouldn't wear
that because you're of a certain age you
know and these are ladies that are
colorful and amazing and fashion icons
and living their lives and I think it's
important to like you know have people
like this spot
you know I was just actually reading
this horrific article yesterday that my
friend Liz Goldwyn pointed out to me
this writer she was actually an editor
at Vogue and I was so I was shocked that
she wrote something like this she was
saying that Helena Christensen who's 50
went to a party and she was wearing
jeans and a strapless bustier and she
said it was completely inappropriate for
her to be flaunting that much skin at
her age and mind you she looks fantastic
when I'm hearing about this article I
googled it you know and I read it it's a
Daily Mail article which is obviously
clickbait so I chose not to share it
because I was like oh yes I'm offended
and outraged but that's exactly what
they want from us yeah they want me to
have everyone read it and be outraged
but I did find it disturbing because
they were basically saying she was
saying that once you're past
childbearing age you're you know you
shouldn't be wearing clothes like that
or you should you know open you know the
you know pave let the other the young
people have their chance and I mean if
you can see this picture of Halina
Christians and you'd be like she looks
so hot and she's perfect and she says
things in this article like no matter
how invisible your bingo wings are I
don't know that means well you know like
when you know this what is that oh you
try say what are you talking about and
they she said that it's okay for men
because they can procreate at any age
essentially but once you are you know
beyond childbearing years you shouldn't
dress like that and I just found it
amazing that she used to be the editor
in at British Vogue for like in the
night perspective it was really shocking
and you know anyway I just it's a real
interesting conversation though about
like ageism and and how it you know
we're we treat women of a certain age
and it's one of those things that I feel
like it's important to stand up for I
almost retired a few years ago thinking
like oh I should I'm 40 I should stop
doing striptease what if I don't look as
good as I used to and then I thought
like wait you have - I have female
followers and I have to stand for
something and I think it's important to
have
samples of eroticism and sensuality in
all different phases of life and to set
examples for that because I look to
people that are older than me like
Jennifer Lopez and you know Gwen Stefani
and all these people that I am like oh
she's sexy you know like I can be like
that too so I think it's important as
much as it's and you know it's not
always easy and you open yourself up to
criticism it's important to some people
to see examples of this so here here
well DITA this has been so fun I really
appreciate you taking the time and we're
gonna link to everything that you
mentioned in the show notes so people
can find all of that very easily and for
people listening that's just a Tim Doug
/a podcast and if you search DITA the
ITA it'll pop right up
now I mentioned these social accounts
where people can learn what you're up to
see what you're up to
also more accurately in terms of at Dita
Von Teese so on Twitter Instagram and
Facebook are you more active on one than
the others I'm mostly active on
Instagram I have to say but I definitely
use Facebook and a little bit of Twitter
I can't help it it was the first one
still good and I do you've any current
projects or upcoming projects that you
would like people to check out or keep
an eye out for yeah well I have my
lingerie line which is it like
Bloomingdale's and Nordstrom and a lot
of online retailers I'm working on
another book called fashioning the fom
total which will come out it's a follow
up to my my beauty book that I that I
wrote and that one will come out I think
in September 2020 and this year I'm
touring with a new show kicking off in
Australia in November and then doing
like eight weeks in Europe March twenty
twenty through April and then I think
I'll do the US sometime in 2020 as well
well you have a very exciting year two
years in many years ahead of you thank
you so much for taking the time thanks
for talking to me this is really fun do
you have any closing comments requests
anything at all that you'd like to say
before we wrap up I can't think of
anything which is which is the most
common response that's what I think we
covered plenty and I really hope people
stay tuned and I will provide everything
that we spoke about in the show notes as
I mentioned so thanks to you for being
here and thanks to everyone for tuning
in and until next time craft your own
path do not try to be the best of
someone else try to discover and also
piece together the unique path that only
you can forge so on that note until next
time bye bye hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun for
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in if your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by linked
in jobs hiring can be hard really hard
and it can also be super super expensive
and painful if you get it wrong I
certainly have had that experience
firsthand multiple times and I am NOT
eager to repeat it so I tried to do as
much betting as possible on the front
end and today with more qualified
candidates than ever you need a solution
you need a platform that helps you to
find the right people for your business
LinkedIn jobs does exactly that more
than 600 million users visit LinkedIn to
learn make connections grows
professionals and more than ever
discover new job opportunities in fact
overall LinkedIn members add 15 new
skills to their profiles and apply to
thirty five job posts every two seconds
that's a great new step LinkedIn does
the legwork to match you to your most
qualified candidates so that you can
focus on the hiring process getting the
person into your company who will
transform your business they make sure
your job post gets in front of the
people with the right hard skills and
soft skills to meet your requirements
they've made it as easy as possible so
check it out to get $50 off of your
first job post go to linkedin.com slash
tim again that's linkedin.com slash tim
to get $50 off of your first job post
terms and conditions apply check it out
linkedin.com slash Tim this episode of
the Tim Ferriss show's brought to you by
athletic greens I get us all the time if
I could only take one supplement what
would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all in one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with the to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of the
one dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time an extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens comm forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
dot-com forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase
you
[Applause]